ce trudeau bonjour bonsoir je trudeau je
vais pas vous demander ce à toutes les
missions mais la petite exception oui ou
non si possible pour les deux petites
première question est ce que vous
regrettez
cette campagne qui était pas tellement
désirée par les canadiens non la réalité
c'est que je comprends que les gens ça
leur tente pas d'aller en élection ça
leur tente on ne reviennent pas talent
tampon ne vient de passer une année
difficile un an et demi difficile on
veut la reprise on veut avancer mais il
ya des grosses décisions à prendre en
tant que pays sur comment en finir avec
la pandémie comment on va continuer les
gens méritent de pouvoir faire le choix
c'est votre troisième campagne fédérale
monsieur trudeau peu importe le résultat
ce que ça sera la dernière mais nous on
peut nécessairement
et je pense pas à ça je pense à tout ce
qu'on est en train de faire ensemble et
tout ce que je veux pour en faire et
c'est pour ça que avec les décisions qui
vont se prendre dans les mois à venir
pendant un an pendant deux ans mais
maintenant je suis excité gentil
beaucoup les responsabilités qu'on va
avoir en forme en même temps monsieur
trudeau la quatrième vague on le voit
elle s'accélère le nombre de cas
augmente au pays vous êtes en train dé
si vous faire réélire plutôt que de
diriger les opérations alors est ce que
cette campagne électorale elle ne nuit
pas quand même aux efforts pour
combattre la pandémie tout d'abord on
comprend que cette quatrième vague une
vague surtout des non vaccinés il ya la
plupart des canadiens presque 80% des
gens éligibles qui se sont fait vacciner
ils ont fait leur d'avoir on est en
train passe à travers pour beaucoup de
gens qui n'ont pas de problème avec les
vaccins les masses tout ça oui il faut
continuer d'être vigilant il faut
continuer d'encourager tout le monde de
se faire vacciner mais on peut aussi
commencent à reprendre la vraie vie et
de comprendre que oui c'est un moment on
a appris comment gérer une crise immense
et on doit appliquer ces mêmes
réflexions à la crise climatique à la
crise du logement on a des grosses
décisions à prendre maintenant qu'ils
sont importants que les canadiens fasse
entendre par leur vote monsieur trudeau
vous a dit quand même les moyens pour
compléter vos engagements vous devez
laisser des projets sur la table non
complétées et là vous êtes confrontés ma
foi une vague de rage
par la crise de la pandémie au fond avec
cette vague d'orages à ce qu'on peut pas
se demander si cette élection ne devient
pas un référendum sur votre leadership à
vous je pense pas parce que on voit la
vague de rage oui des gens qui refusent
de se faire vacciner des gens qui sont
en train de manifester de façon assez
intense et même violente mais c'est une
petite minorité on voit le canada et est
à la tête de la planète en termes de
vaccination les gens veulent qu'on passe
à travers on appris des grosses
décisions on va continuer d'en prendre
mais c'est normal que quand on prend
deux grosses décisions on veuille la
confiance et l'appui de la population
directement en 2019 on n'a pas parlé de
pandémie qui on est déjà rendu le 5e
plus long gouvernement minoritaire dans
l'histoire du pays je pense que dans une
crise comme ça dans un moment pivot
comme ça oui on devrait vérifier avec
les gens qu'on va aller encore plus vite
pour les changements climatiques on va
aller encore plus vite pour les familles
pour les vénérables si ce qu'ont appris
pendant la pandémie avant d'avancer je
pense que ces deux mises d'avoir une
élection ce trudeau le 13 ou deux jours
avant le déclenchement j'avais annoncé
la vaccination obligatoire pour tous les
fonctionnaires fédéraux
qu'est ce qui va arriver aux
fonctionnaires qui refusent de se faire
vacciner air canada c'est clair pas de
vaccin pas d'emploi quelle est votre
position
mais c'est aussi très clair pas de
vaccination vous n'allez pas pouvoir
embarquer dans l'avion cet automne n'est
pas pouvoir prendre un train alors ça
c'est quelque chose d'important qu'on a
prise comme décision mais on l'avait pas
non c'est juste la veille de l'élection
on en avait parlé une semaine deux
semaines avant que je fait une annonce
avec mai legault sur les garderies donc
les gens voyaient souvenir évidemment on
va travailler avec les syndicats on va
travailler avec les employeurs dans la
fonction publique pour s'assurer que oui
c'était pas vacciner tu pourras pas
travailler
tu pourrais pas travailler c'est de te
présenter au travail au bureau parce que
ça met les autres à risque bon vous avez
vu les manifestants vendredi évidemment
et là ça on a l'impression que ça va
aller en s'accélérant ces manifestations
la qu'est-ce que vous êtes aux
fonctionnaires de revenu canada qui
travaillent dans son sous-sol à toronto
ou à gatineau à shawinigan pourquoi lui
devrait se faire avec tout d'abord je
dire merci aux fonctionnaires de revenu
canada parce que c'est eux qui ont livré
la pcu c'est eux qui ont été là pour
aider avec des mesures extraordinaires
pour qu'on puisse passer à travers de
cette pandémie et qu'ils l'ont fait
d'ailleurs à partir de leur sous-sol de
leur leur salon
deuxièmement la fonction publique au
canada est déjà
extrêmement extrêmement haut niveau de
vaccination donc on voit que c'est des
gens qui respectent la science oui il ya
des gens qui veulent faire le choix de
ne pas se faire vacciner mais ils
pourront pas mettre les autres à risque
par des gens ils ont fait leur devoir
ils comprennent que de se faire vacciner
c'est pas juste se protéger soi même
c'est de protéger les autres cd protéger
nos aînés c'est de protéger nos enfants
que mon enfant de 7 ans qui peut pas se
faire vacciner il faut que tout le monde
a sa part au quai mais conséquence mais
qui sont à définir avec les syndicats ne
sais pas qu'est ce qui va arriver à
quelqu'un qui refuse effectivement mais
on peut être très très clair pour les
voyageurs par exemple et on a on appris
des choix très clair et d'ailleurs le
fait qu' un débat là-dessus dans cette
élection souligne à quel point oui des
gros shows à apprendre très bien parlant
des bords vous promettez depuis le début
de la campagne des milliards 10
milliards aux provinces pour la santé
pour engager des médecins des
infirmières pour les les attend pour les
achats celle d'el et les maisons pour
personnes âgées
monsieur le goût vous a répondu cette
semaine et le jeu site il a dit hey je
lui promets médecins et moi j'ai besoin
d'à jean mais sans condition est-ce que
c'est clair pour régler cette histoire
là qui meurent pas un transfert sans
conditions vers les problèmes ce que les
gens veulent c'est ce que les gens ont
besoin c'est les bons services qui livre
qui font un impact dans leur vie pour
eux oui on va toujours respecté les
champs de compétences qu'on va le faire
au partenariat mais on a pu le faire
pendant un an et demi déjà avec des
transferts pour la pandémie avec des
partenariats j'ai signé énormément
d'accord avec monsieur legault justement
pour livrer de l'argent directement dans
les poches pour la pandémie on va
continuer de le faire mais on va
s'assurer que ce soit l'argent qui va à
la bonne place pour vraiment livré pour
les gens et on a confiance dans les
provinces dans les choix du mot juste
pour être clair mme se trouvait le 28
milliards sans condition que vous
demandent les provinces oui ça arrivera
jamais on va en discuter mais on a
démontré qu'on ait la dent pendant la
crise et on sera là pour l'avenir aussi
pcr eu beaucoup de gens qui se plaignent
de la pénurie de main d'oeuvre qui fait
mal partout pays vous dise fermez le
robinet c'est à six à huit cent mille
canadiens encore qui touche la cette
prestation d'urgence est-ce que vous
allez la reconduire de mois en mois
jusqu'à l'éternité non évidemment non et
on a déjà réduite jusqu'à 500 $ par
semaine durant jusqu'à 300 dollars par
semaine plutôt que 500 parce que il ya
un moins grand besoin avec la reprise
économique mais aussi aussi qu'il ya
certains secteurs dont les arts la
culture par exemple où les gens en
arrache encore à cause de cette pandémie
qui continue on n'est pas tout à fait de
retour à la normale donc on va continuer
d'être là pour les gens qui ont besoin
et la pénurie de main d'oeuvre elle
était là avant la pandémie c'est sûr que
la pandémie a exacerbé certaines
conditions certaines situations mais on
va continuer de travailler mais pénurie
de main-d'oeuvre vous faites moi
l'immigration la formation mais on
reconnaît aussi qu'il ya beaucoup de
gens qui pendant cette cette prose
pandémique 2 d'un an d'un an et demi on
réfléchit à leur carrière à leur
direction ils veulent pas revenir dans
les mêmes emplois qu'ils avaient avant
c'est quelque chose qui arrive on va
être là pour les soutenir on voyait
aussi est l'ordre les employeurs ce qui
amène un déficit énorme où on s'est
retourné en étant raynaud vendredi on
sort la réunion pour un milliard de plus
pour le passeport vaccinale ce trudeau
il ya des gens qui commencent
sérieusement à s'inquiéter en dix ans ce
qu'on vaut pour refiler une facture et
éhontée à nos enfants
commençons d'abord par comprendre que
quand il a fallu qu'on passe à un arrêt
de l'économie à cause de la pandémie
fallait qu'on soit là pour appuyer les
gens parce qu'ils n'allaient pas pouvoir
payer leur loyer à payer leur épicerie
donc on était là heureusement on avait
le meilleur bilan économique d'angers 7
on appuie donc est versée pour aider les
gens pour les empêcher de voir mettre
leurs loyers sur leur carte de crédit
par exemple payer 19 % d'impôts pardon
d'intérêt pendant que nous un
gouvernement fédéral on emprunte à peine
1% on sait aussi qu'on arrive et si on
s'est endetté pour que les gens et pas à
s'endetter et sur ses projets ce la
bonne raison pour pour des raisons
morales c'est la bonne chose à faire
parce que ça nous a permis de passer à
travers et de rouvrir de façon plus
rapide notre économie mais le plein de
retours 30 secondes dans ce bloc le
plein de retour à un équilibre on dirait
que ça vous préoccupe pas du tout au
contraire on a démontré dans le budget
2011 2021 il ya quelques mois qu'on va
continuer de baisser la dette comme
pourcentage de notre pib donc on reste
dans sur une
direction responsable même avec tous les
investissements qu'on est en train de
faire les garderies 30 milliards de
dollars pour des garderies à travers le
pays les gens disent oh mon dieu c'est
trop cher monsieur autour dit oh mon
dieu c'est trop cher faudrait pas le
faire il va renverser ça mais on le sait
que des garderies les places en garderie
c'est bon pour les familles c'est bon
pour l'économie aussi merci monsieur
trudeau parlons de l'afghanistan parce
que vous saviez depuis le printemps que
les américains allaient se retirer que
les talibans pouvaient prendre le
pouvoir pourquoi est ce que le canada a
tant tardé à commencer le rapatriement
de ces afghans qui ont travaillé avec
les canadiens parfois au péril de leur
vie pourquoi s'attarder autant sa patte
retarder autant on a travaillé avec les
communautés on a travaillé avec les
anciens interprète afghan a pour
justement commencé le processus on ne
put en rapatrier autour de 3700 avec 10
ses vols tout au long du mois du mois
d'août on aurait voulu en faire plus
mais on était limité par la situation
avec les talibans par les américains par
les vols qui peuvent rentrer et sortir
mais on n'abandonne pas on continue le
travail parce que on s'attend à en
accueillir des dizaines de milliers au
canada c'est ce que les canadiens et
québécois veulent ils veulent
reconnaître ces gens là qui qui fuient
la terreur on va être là pour eux on va
continuer le travail mais sur le coup en
regard des saints on voyait bien que
pour tous les pays c'était assez
chaotique tout le monde a été pris par
surprise mais on a le sentiment quand
même que pour le canada ça a été plus
compliqué y avait des pays qui ont gardé
une représentation diplomatique sur
place qui était à l'aéroport qui pouvait
accueillir les gens qui allaient en
autobus les chercher qui les amenait
qu'il y faisait pas assez à travers
cette foule qu'elle veut à travers ces
barrages d'aliments le canada n'a pas
fait ça au contraire on a fait ça en
avait des membres des forces armées qui
sont allés chercher des gens et c'est
pour ça que le canada se compare très
bien au nombre de ressortissants aux
etats-unis à la grande-bretagne qui
avaient une plus grande équipe sur
terrain mais tous les autres pays
européens
on se compare très favorablement aux ne
fait énormément parce que on est là pour
les gens et surtout on est prêt à en
accueillir beaucoup plus que d'autres
pays mais il y avait beaucoup de
militaires qui ont l'impression qu'on
les a abandonnés quand même c'est à vous
de ce que vous avez à vous partager ce
sentiment je comprends à quel point
c'est extrêmement difficile cette
situation c'est à déchirer le coeur de
voir les taliban prendre contrôle après
20 ans ou de travailler sur le terrain
avec tant de sacrifices avec tant de
pertes de vies et d'efforts et d'argent
canadien investi là-dedans ça brise le
coeur et on veut continuer d'être là on
en a accueilli pardon comment vous à
l'élysée lit maintenant comment faire
sortir du pays passe il reste à peu près
300 familles on nous dit 2000 personnes
on va en accueillir beaucoup plus que ça
on est en train de travailler des
partenaires dans les régions pour voir
si est en train de mettre la paire frais
des gens qui ont travaillé mais enfin
mettre la pression sur les talibans pour
s'assurer que des gens qui ont la
documentation canadiennes puissent
sortir on est partenaires régionaux qui
vont aider à ce niveau là on va aussi
travailler avec les pays avoisinants
pour pouvoir ramener des gens qui ont
fui des revers d'autres pays ça va pas
être facile c'est une situation
désastreuse en afghanistan c'est
vraiment difficile et pénible à voir
mais on va continuer de faire tout ce
qu'on peut pour sauver le plus de gens
possible parce que c'est ce que les
canadiens s'attendent de nous est-ce que
vous avez été déçu de ne pas avoir été
informés des détails de ce retrait des
américains
au contraire tout pendant ce processus
là ont eu des échanges réguliers avec
tous nos alliés avec j'ai parlé au
président j'ai parlé à bien du monde
président biden pendant la rencontre du
g7 mais mes ministres ont parlé
directement leurs homologues on était
extrêmement coordonner les forces armées
canadiennes étaient intégrés et
partenaires avec les forces américaines
comme on l'est souvent donc la relation
avec les états unis est vrai bien elle
va très bien parce qu'on se demande
qu'est ce qui se passe avec la frontière
par exemple comment ça se fait comment
expliquer qu'on n'ait pas réussi à
coordonner une ouverture simultanée des
deux côtés vous avez ouvert de votre
côté les américains empêchent encore les
canadiens de rentrer par là la frontière
terrestre sauf que les américains ils
permettaient les gens d'aller en floride
à noël qu'ils soient vaccinées ou non et
nous on permettait pas aux américaines
il y avait toujours communication la
team bien vous avez pas vous n'arrivez
pas à vous faire entendre et finissent
pas au contraire on a toujours très bien
coordonnées mais chaque pays va prendre
ses propres décisions pour gérer la
pandémie on a vu que la pandémie était
différente au canada qu'elle a été aux
états unis parce qu'on a géré
différemment et je pense qu'on a très
bien géré la pandémie merci monsieur
truc mais ce trudeau la planète brûle
des images de catastrophes même du
canada ont fait le tour du monde
on sait par le giec notamment que le
canada va se réchauffer deux fois plus
vite que les autres pays mais le nord
trois fois puis v et quand vous avez
fait de nouvelles annonces pour vos
cibles il ya quelques semaines quelques
mois vous allez annoncer des cibles
inférieure à celle des états unis alors
on peut se demander pourquoi vous n'avez
pas le même sentiment d'urgence face à
cette crise des changements climatiques
que les états unis je comprends que les
cibles sont importantes et on est on est
des cibles extrêmement ambitieuse
jusqu'à 45 % en dessous des niveaux de
2003 2005 en 2030 mais l'important c'est
le niveau d'ambition qu'on craint caunes
pour pouvoir réaliser on a au cours des
5 5 6 dernières années mis un prix sur
la pollution partout au pays on a banni
les plastiques à usage nocifs
aujourd'hui j'ai annoncé que les
émissions du secteur pétrolier ne vont
que des cendres ne vont que baisser dans
les années à venir il y aura plus
d'expansion au vu de l'accroissement des
émissions on est en train d'avoir un
plan extrêmement ambitieux mais aussi
extrêmement réaliste et pratique mais
moins moins ambitieux que celui des
états unis les états unis ont promis de
prix sur la pollution à inuh on a une
des prix sur la pollution les plus les
plus robustes au monde alors avec tout
ce que vous avez nommé ray de vos
réalisations
comment expliquer que le canada était le
seul pays du g7 avoir augmenté ses
émissions de gaz est atteint parce que
pendant
quand on a pris le pouvoir on avait un
gouvernement qui n'a rien fait pour
lutter pour compte les changements
climatiques et il a fallu qu'on commence
à zéro en 2015 et 2 0 on est arrivé
maintenant avec une approche qui va nous
amener à
dépasser largement les sites de monsieur
harper sauf évidemment si monsieur
o'toole nous ramène en arrière comme il
veut il veut reprendre les mêmes sites
d'art peur qu'on a déjà dépassé on a
beaucoup plus à faire on a démontré
notre capacité de le faire mais vous
avez mis plusieurs années à rajuster
vaut aussi pour bien le reconnaître vous
voyez parce que c'est pas juste une
question de donner c'est n'importe qui
peut donner des cibles est-ce qu'on peut
créer un plan pour y arriver dans un
pays qui vivent qui est trop froid
l'hiver trop chaud l'été où les espaces
sont vastes oui on est juste un ami le
travail pour faire un plan concret qui
vont livrer cette ambition le rapport du
giec encore une fois cet été a lancé
vraiment une alerte rouge pour
l'humanité interpelle aussi le canada
allez-vous mettre fin aux subventions
mesures fiscales très grand trait aux
industries fossiles aux forces et quand
la fin de la récréation que ce trou
d'eau c'est maintenant c'est depuis
plusieurs années qu'on a mis un prix sur
la pollution à travers le pays la
réalité c'est que l'honneur et on est en
voie d'éliminer les industries et les
subventions aux industries sauf que à
l'intérieur des subventions qui sont
cités souvent par le npd on a des
investissements pour convertir des
usines de
dassier pour utiliser l'électricité
plutôt que le charbon on a des mesures
pour pour aider l'industrie pétrolière à
réduire leur méthane on est en train de
mettre des mesures conditionnelle pour
améliorer les émissions parce que veut
pas l'alberta et l'industrie pétrolière
va devoir faire partie de notre avenir
nette zéro et c'est justement avec leur
innovation et leur leadership et leur
emploi qu'on va y arriver où il ya quand
même transporter une jolie poursuivre le
projet pas question de l'intérêt on a on
ne put on veut limiter les les
augmentations des missions on va les
réduire et un oléoduc c'est la meilleure
façon la moins polluante de transporter
du pétrole pendant qu'on en a besoin et
réduire les productions oui oui on veut
réduire les émissions surtout si les
émissions qui sont et qui attend on voit
on va continuer à vos besoins du pétrole
pendant quelques années mais si on peut
décarboniser si on peut innover pour
réduire l'impact pendant qu'on a des
voitures encore à carburants fossiles
c'est mieux pour nous c'est mieux pour
l'environnement vous avez annoncé
justement aujourd'hui des mesures mais
on a toujours notre programme pourquoi
avoir annoncé vos mesures sur les
changements climatiques aujourd'hui en
dehors de l'ensemble des programmes
qu'on a une vision d'ensemble
la vision d'ensemble
elle est là dans notre notre vision de
des 100 pour 100 véhicules électriques
en 2035 50% de nouveaux véhicules d'ici
2030 on est là avec un plan ambitieux et
la plateforme entière va sortir dans les
jours à venir est ce que ça prend pour
un électrochoc
pour lutter contre les changements
climatiques et meriem et c'est
exactement ce qu'on est en train de
faire quand on quand on a tenu bon
contre les promesses qu'ils voulaient
pas de prix sur la pollution et quand on
continue à augmenter nos cibles on est
là pour l'ambition mais c'est pas juste
l'ambition c'est la capacité de livrer
les municipalités du canada vous demande
1 2 milliard pour les aider c'est oui ou
c'est non on a toujours travaillé avec
les municipalités mais on va le faire
avec les provinces aussi dans le respect
des compétences mais oui ou non le 2
milliards ont besoin de c'est urgent de
2 milliards a déjà envoyé des milliards
de dollars aux municipalités on va
continuer d'être la porte donc oui à 2
milliards je vais regarder la demande
tels concrètes mais on a toujours été
partenaire avec les lives et l'on va
construire seul fait de belles et
grandes annonces aussi à côté greta
tandberg il est venu au delà de l'image
qui était projeté de la promesse était
de porter deux milliards d'arbres vous
en avez planté combien jusqu'à
maintenant on en a planté d'abord planté
des arbres faux faux faux l'époux c'est
d'abord ça prend un certain montant pour
peut pas tout simplement pas enclencher
des graines il faut garder des arts du
ca france exane et pour pousser au cours
d'un dossier des pensionnats autochtones
maintenant pensionnat pour les
autochtones la découverte de centaines
de corse a bouleversé beaucoup de gens
mais vous vous étiez au courant quand
même depuis un certain temps puisque
tout ça avait été
rapporté dans par la commission vérité
et réconciliation
qu'est ce qui a été fait depuis 2007 et
2015 donc sk est à feu a été fait
jusqu'à cette découverte est d'abord en
2017 on ne donnait de l'argent justement
pour permettre à ces recherches pour
retrouver les dépouilles c'était 28
milliards de dollars qu'ils ont commencé
à utiliser qui est en train d'être
utilisé cet été en même temps vous allez
donner dix fois plus après un conseil
weave quand j'ai vu de plus en plus de
besoins mais l'important cauche aller
visiter en saskatchewan a kawa sas pour
voir justement c'était la deuxième
communauté on en avait découvert les
dépouilles on a pu annoncer en même
temps la fin de la dpj pour les enfants
autochtones que les jeunes autochtones
aller pour à risque allait pouvoir
rester dans leur communauté soit ça se
fait pas en deux semaines comme un nom
ça fait des années qu'on travaille
dessus avec les peuples attendent pour
pouvoir pas juste pleuré la perte de ses
enfants depuis des décennies mais de
dire à partir d'aujourd'hui ça se fera
plus les enfants risquent vont rester
dans leur communauté c'est seul travail
de partenariat qui se fait pas du jour
au lendemain qui s'est préparé depuis
des années qu'on a pu heureusement
annoncé et démontrer comme partenariat
positif dans un moment de tra 10
terrible est ce que les responsables
s'il y en a qui sont encore en vie
doivent faire face à la justice c'est ce
que le gouvernement fédéral doit
financer une enquête pour qu'on
comprenne les circonstances entourant le
décès de ses petits-enfants oui je pense
qu'on devrait s'assurer que ya une
redevabilité et qu'ils aient des
conséquences mais c'est pas un
politicien de décider si on dépose des
accusations contre quelqu'un faveur
c'est ça oui qui je pense que tout le
monde est en faveur de comprendre les
horreurs qui se sont faits et de
s'assurer que ceux qui sont responsables
c'est un travail que je continue à faire
avec l'église catholique malheureusement
qui n'est pas tout à fait au rendez vous
pour faire des excuses ou pour pour
comprendre leurs responsabilités ou
reprendre prendre acte de leur
responsabilité là dedans on a du travail
à faire et sur la question des droits
territoriaux parce que c'est un peu seul
le noeud du problème avec la loi sur les
indiens mais est-ce que vous avez avancé
sur cette question là puisqu'on se
souvient tous c'est juste avant la
pandémie on arrive sans que ça fait un
siècle mais quand même les
revendications de droits territoriaux
des oueds souhaitait mais est-ce que ça
avance et depuis ou bien ce qu'on risque
de revoir encore des blocages
ferroviaire nom savant cyr toujours des
risques de blocage est toujours des
risques de différents mais en même temps
ce qu'on est en train de faire et ce
qu'on a fait c'est de sortir plusieurs
communautés de la loi sur les indiens à
leur rythme en partenariat pour leur
donner le contrôle de leur propre
gouvernement de leur propre service
c'est un travail de longue haleine ça
prend ça prend des années pour défaire
les torts qui ont été faits sur des
siècles mais le progrès se fait à tout
là tous les jours la loi sur les indiens
est ce que ça faudrait l'éliminer
wilfred la jarrie et un but mais est ce
que c'est commencer à ce que si luis et
c'est commencer et c'est fait pour
plusieurs communautés il y en a d'autres
qui sont pas prêt encore de le faire
selon eux et on avance alors et ne peut
pas imposer des solutions d'ottawa sur
les communautés autochtones il faut
travailler en partenariat ça prend un
peu plus de temps mais c'est comme ça
qu'on arrive aux bonnes solutions qui
sont générés par la communauté elle-même
donc oui on va en finir avec la loi sur
les indiens mais elle leur est bon notre
merci mais je rebondis une seconde là
dessus est ce que de notre vivant parce
que votre père espérait ça jean chrétien
qui a été ministre espérait ça à
l'époque est ce qu'on va voir sa une un
nouveau pacte avec les peuples
autochtones au canada sans loi sur les
indiens où ils pourront être
propriétaire ou y aura des les ententes
territoriales ce que beaucoup pensent
ils de notre vivant va voir ça oui oui
absolument peut-être pas à 100% par tous
parce qu'il ya des communautés qui sont
qui ont plus de travail à faire que
d'autres mais on a déjà plusieurs des
communautés qui sont en train d'être
complètement sorti de la loi sur les
indiens qui sont en train de réussir de
façon économique qui sont en train de
contrôler leur éducation leur système de
santé etc des modèles pour pour tous les
autres à suivre et on va être là pour
aider pour financer pour appuyer dans la
bière cours cette rude au je sais pas
s'il ya deux semaines quand vous êtes
allés prendre un café ou un thé j'en
sais rien avec marie saimone une femme
par ailleurs remarquable je peux vous
avez pu dire quelques mots en français
voir si elle prenait des cours de
français avez vous pu oui j'ai essayé un
pull français avec elle vous savez que
il ya eu 600 plainte au commissaire des
langues officielles
suite à la nomination d'une femme je lui
dis qui peut être remarquable par
ailleurs mais qui ne parle pas français
quel message envoie aux communautés
francophones de ce pays monsieur trudeau
est ce que vous avez vu le tout tout la
contreverse de cet été
est ce que quand vous regardez en
arrière vous êtes c'était peut-être une
erreur non ce n'était pas une erreur
mais écoutez j'ai réfléchi longuement à
ce choix je sais que ça n'allait pas
être facile à faire sur le bilinguisme
chez toujours là pour défendre nos
langues officielles je les ai posées aux
juges de la cour suprême par exemple
pour moi c'est extrêmement important
mais on est dans un moment maintenant où
je pense que mary 100 mg devait être
l'exception et non un précédent mais
l'exception parce que notre pays a
besoin de mieux comprendre et d'être là
pour les communautés autochtones qui
s'il affaire de tous et mairie à la
capacité de rassembler les gens elle
s'est engagée à apprendre le français
elle est en train d'y travailler neil a
grandi au nord du québec à un moment où
on enseignait pas le français aux jeunes
autochtones essor c'est dommage ça
changeait heureusement non comprend
s'appuie votre désir de réconciliation
mais vous comprenez monsieur trudeau et
la réaction des communautés francophones
au québec ailleurs partout au canada qui
se dit ici la gouverneure générale s'est
pas assez important qu'elle parle
français qui sommes-nous non je
comprends ce sentiment et je comprends
tout à fait les gens qui ont partagé
cette cette préoccupation est mon si je
la partage je voudrais pas que ça
devienne à quelque chose qui arrivent
régulièrement mais dans le moment dans
lequel on était on avait besoin de
quelqu'un qui s'engage apprendre le
français mais qui va être là pour aider
les communautés et le pays à guérir dans
ce moment de réconciliation si le choix
que j'ai fait et je l'assumé mais
surtout de la sécurité des citoyens mais
encore aux les fusillades explose en
france à montréal ces jours derniers ces
dernières semaines les grandes villes
vous demande de prendre vous mêmes à
savoir la responsabilité de
l'interdiction des armes de poing alors
que vous leur lancée ça dans leur cour
et qu'ils impulsent implore de reprendre
cette responsable et de l'interdire
pourquoi pas tout d'abord il faut
comprendre que depuis les débuts honneur
et pour renforcer le contrôle des armes
à feu depuis le mois de mai passé c'est
maintenant illégal de posséder d'acheter
et d'utiliser un pardon d'acheter
d'utiliser ou de vendre un arme d'assaut
au canada ça c'est fait qu'il ya plus
d'armes d'assaut ligue au canada ça
c'était une grande étape on va continuer
de prendre des étapes y compris de
travail avec les villes à pour bannir
les armes de poing mais on sait que
c'est pas la réalité à travers le pays
qui est que les gens sont prêts à faire
ça il ya des villes comme montréal comme
toronto qui veulent vraiment et on va en
faire plus pour travailler avec eux
parce que ça paraît incohérent de
laisser à des petits territoires une
telle responsabilité
alors que vous n'hésitez pas à prendre
des politiques pour l'ensemble du
territoire canadien
pourquoi pas le faire rapidement c'est
une attente
parce qu'on n'est pas rendu là encore
parce que on est rendu au point où oui
il va falloir qu'on continue de
renforcer le contrôle des armes à feu
les conservateurs veulent remettre sur
le marché les armes d'assaut d'ailleurs
c'est un choix très clair que les gens
veulent prendre on va continuer
d'avancer mais on va travailler avec les
villes pour bannir les armes de poing
sur l'arrestation d'un dirigeant de
huawei même où joe les procédures
judiciaires ne sont pas encore terminées
mais une fois qu'elles le seront
utilement est-ce que c'est pas une
décision politique
est ce que vous pourriez ne pas
l'extrader aux états unis qu'elle rentre
chez elle pour sauver les deux michael
qui sont emprisonnés depuis
993 jour aujourd'hui
d'abord je déplore
également la situation des deux magots
juger par la leurs familles directement
au travail pour les sortir de cet
emprisonnement et juste depuis les
débuts moi ma responsabilité c'est aussi
de démontrer aux chinois ja à tous les
pays du monde que ce n'est pas en
arrêtant des voyageurs ou des citoyens
canadiens qu'on va pouvoir avoir le
résultat politique qu'on veut ça peut
pas fonctionner comme ça donc on est
pris à devoir dire que oui on a un
système de jeu ce qui va suivre son
cours mais non on va pas se plier du
chantage pour pour qui il n'est qu'en
liberté nos deux citoyens oui mais c'est
pour sauver des vies et vous avez le
pouvoir de le faire pour sauver des vies
la juge louise arbour avait dit que vous
vouliez même interrompre les procédures
c'était en mai ça mettrait à risque tous
les voyageurs canadiens tous les
travailleurs canadiens qui se retrouvent
en chine ou ailleurs dans le monde si
les pays savent qu'ils peuvent faire du
chantage pour avoir un résultat police
politique qui désirent en mettant de la
pression sur le canada via ses citoyens
et pour moi de défendre l'intégrité de
notre système de justice et la fermeté
avec laquelle on va défendre tous les
citoyens y compris les maiko mais aussi
tous les citoyens qui font du tourisme
qui travaillent ailleurs dans le monde
faut être fermes dans son visage et pas
de ne pas l'extrader on
va regarder toutes les étapes
nécessaires au travail avec nos
partenaires les pays du monde entier
sont en train de mettre la pression sur
la chine parce que ce qu'ils voient qui
se passe au canadien pour espacer pour
leurs citoyens aussi passé prévu comme à
10 et les vous avez le droit de ne pas
l'extrader après un processus judiciaire
après le processus judiciaire il ya des
étapes à suivre on vous regarde et à ce
niveau là mais pour moi ça ça demeure
des principes extrêmement important de
protéger tous les canadiens justin
trudeau on a été
impeccable dans le chronomètre merci
merci' seulement merci de vous êtes prêt
n'est l'exercice